"The Suicide Squad" is, by its very nature,
a violent film.
The comic books the film is based around center
on a task force composed mostly of supervillains
forced against their will by the cold-hearted
Amanda Waller to take on missions no one in
their right mind would want to do.
"I thought you were the crazy one."
"I am."
Waller's combatants are criminals, not heroes
— at least not in the traditional sense
— and each of them has an explosive device
implanted at the base of their skulls.
In other words, even if someone from Waller's
Taskforce X were to somehow survive their
mission, there's still a chance Waller might
just pop their head like a grape.
James Gunn's latest adaptation of the team
"The Suicide Squad" goes all the way on the
gruesome and gory nature of the comic book
source material.
In fact, the entire opening of the film introduces
us to a new character named Savant, makes
us care about him, connects him with characters
fans already know like Captain Boomerang and
Harley Quinn, only to have Waller blow his
head off when he flees the mission.
In fact, every single character other than
Harley and Rick Flag dies during the opening
— each death more horrific than the last.
In short: when James Gunn says that there
was a scene from "The Suicide Squad" that
Warner Bros. thinks went too far when compared
with the entire grisly opening, you know it's
pretty bad.
So what is the one scene Gunn had to fight
to keep in the film?
"You're supposed to be decisive."
"And I've decided you should eat a big bag
of d---s."
When Rick Flag is captured after the disastrous
first team's beach assault, the second team
led by Bloodsport is sent on a mission to
save Flag.
Waller tells Bloodsport that they are to kill
the dangerous people holding Flag "with extreme
prejudice," causing Bloodsport and Peacemaker
to go on a competitive, bloody rampage as
they systematically wipe out everyone in the
camp.
There's just one problem — Flag isn't a
prisoner of war.
In fact, he's being cared for by a resistance
force fighting to bring peace and freedom
to the citizens of Corto Maltese — and that's
who Task Force X just killed.
Oops!
It turns out, this was the scene Warner Bros.
balked at.
When asked if he got any pushback, Gunn told
Variety, "Yeah, I did."
During an early screening for "The Suicide
Squad," Gunn said,
"There [were] some Warner Bros. execs who
brought up, 'Is this the one place that we
go too far?'
I think that's when I added, you know, Amanda
Waller explicitly tells them to go into the
camp and kill everyone, so they are following
her orders, and she is in a way the antagonist
in the film."
Based on fan reaction, though, it seems that
audiences picked up what Gunn was putting
down with the scene.
While the scene of Bloodsport and Peacemaker
one-upping each other by killing their allies
in the Corto Maltesean resistance is certainly
a shocking and brutally ironic bit of ultraviolence
... that's kind of the point.
"The Suicide Squad" is one of those films
where the protagonists aren't necessarily
the good guys in the grander scheme of things.
A scene like the massacre at the rebel camp
is a way to remind the viewer that while they
may be rooting for these characters in the
moment, there is a whole lot of moral grey
area to contend with.
At least, that's how fans on Reddit saw it.
In a general discussion thread for the film
on the "Movies" subreddit, several viewers
shared their thoughts on the controversial
scene.
User u/RazorThought instigated the discussion
by writing,
"Favorite scene was when the Squad is infiltrating
the resistance camp and Bloodsport & Peacemaker
are trying to outdo each other with flashy
kills...just to find out they were accidentally
killing the good guys the whole time.
That scene was A+."
User u/kchuyamewtwo agreed, adding that the
scene forces a necessary recalibration in
the viewer's perception.
They wrote,
"Just reminding us that these are villains
of our superheroes.
Ready to do anything for their personal ambitions."
For u/Arma104, the scene was also indicative
of the improvements that "The Suicide Squad"
made over the infamous 2016 attempt at bringing
the concept to screen.
They wrote,
"This is what impressed me most about the
movie.The first one was hellbent on trying
to make the characters cool and edgy.
This one they're doing the most vile, evil
s—, and are absolute dorks and morons."
"We're bad guys.
It's what we do."
"The Suicide Squad" is in theaters and streaming
on HBO Max now.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.